ciao ragazzi oggi stiamo per fare un
qualcosa di pazzesco
stiamo per creare un dentifricio
sbiancante a casa ed è per questo che ho
il piacere di avere con me e il mio
amico a fare un parco privato per chi
non lo sapesse ragazzi raffaele ruberto
è un biologo molecolare e ha una sua
linea di prodotti beauty dello skin kerr
che io utilizzo già da tanto tempo in
realtà il 57 anni ma mai però a parte il
prestito
raffaele ha quindi come gioco nostro
bravo insieme creato una macchina
fate il cav durante la quarantenne ho
detto senti io ho una certa pazzesca per
fare un dentifricio sbiancante in casa
esatta da qualche settimana e prova ad
un trattamento di quelli che compre su
amazon e non sono contento non sta
funzionando mettere questa specie di
dentiera meraviglioso però continuo a
pensare di essere il cretino che vedeva
un cambiamento mi piacevi link qua sotto
per prendere tramite amazon tutto quello
che utilizzano in modo che se vorrei che
parlo potrete farlo anche voi quindi
posso reclamarli di david è sempre il
nostro assistente della abbiamo lì una
lametta
quindi se credete che questo metto io
sono un burattino avremo bisogno di 10
grammi di carbone vegetale 10 grammi di
argilla rende perché argilla verde cosa
fa lo rende pastoso rende corposo al
prodotto finale aiuta ad assorbire ben
pulita
uno schifo senza essere aggressivo sul
tessuto dei denti la luce dello smalto
10 grammi di glicerina vegetale questo
dà la morbidezza diciamo potessero kiss
setosità deposita anche il prodotto
finale più una cosa estetico per
renderlo più piacevole grazie a 20
grammi di olio di cocco bravissimo si
può ma descritto tube senza ma stai
leggendo bellissimo si può utilizzare
addirittura olio di oliva se proprio non
potete trovare questo però questo è un
po più antibatterico antisettico quindi
aiuta a mantenere diciamola ph della
bocca e infine credo per russo 10 gocce
di menta piperita esteriormente
l'inglese rende il prodotto molto simile
a un decennio tiene l'idea di stare alla
padoan e smalto attraversare il suo di
freschezza
ok è facilissimo farlo è molto facile
iniziamo a fare i piccoli chimici io
adoro questa è una cosa quando lo usi la
bocca diventa proprio nella mera nera se
non vi spaventate
ok questo è importante perché va via non
è una cosa che tinge lo spazzolino ti
diventa nero vero si trova via
l'avventura mente perché il carbone
attivo quando intossicato nello spedale
cosa ti fanno tifano rende carne che
assorbe io ricordo un corso di primo
soccorso si ingerisce dell'acido
dovresti a parte vomitare e bruciare il
pane in modo da carbonizza la lista
farlo e farlo ingerire ma non ingerire
sostanze nocive e propria prima abbiamo
subito adesso prendiamo
biccari servito bene così se ben 10
grammi seria una cosa di guglielmo è che
uno studente alchimista molto perciò
schiera è che per me è una cosa
eccezionale potrei non essere d'accordo
con greco ma con questa noi è motivo
devo giocare qualche cappello quanto
gravi siano stato prossimo facciamo un
vestito che l'alchimista sempre lui fa
la magia lui fa la cover siamo tutto
potete usare ovviamente o slider bosone
non serve avere 10 grammi di argilla e
va a che va a creare la pastosità il
corpo ma allo stesso tempo a dei
principi anche lei assorbenti che
permettono di censo promosso 39enne st
pesa di più questa pesa di più
dimenticato inglese io e te ne
riparliamo in missione abbiamo creato
una nuova lingua di shanghai esatti as
my ragazzata cioè nel senso serie
facilissimo anche in america se bikers
mio meglio e dove sono nato e cresciuto
io sai che le gite di scuola a questi
paesi vecchi e del 600 700 usavano il
carbone attivo capone vegetale con il
miele come detto è prigioniero per
essere sicuri educare per i composti
liquidi invece uso sempre quelle solo
questo ok 10 grammi di glicerina che
sarà quella che ci darà una mano
qualche bella è bella se c'è una canzone
di questo è del 90 tu sei troppo piccola
estremamente giovane anche se c'è il 56
56 anni devono mantenere a faccia da
earth and each sempre anzi a pesare
questi anche il precisino molto fiero ok
guarda se io raggiungo già mischiano si
sa che bello quando tocca di più non
sono affari carattere dolore silvio
gattesco mamma mia faccia esplodere alle
sponde del tutto fatto tra maria dove
ciascuno di cocco sì oggi è venuta con
il profumo di rocco ma per te cena da
sempre si è infilata sotto le ascelle
questo allora questo qui cerchiamo di
dismetterlo per governo è una roba
ragazzata infinita e come farlo fare il
ciambellone tipo noi c'è un melone più
difficile per ora vengono spesso sempre
mese
in realtà in cucina se un po come me tu
sei uno di quelli che si mette ai
fornelli è mai bello è una cosa molto
che cita si può come tutti questi
anziani in italia fanno il ciambellone
perfetto insomma segreto dei segreti
loro maria per esempio per ciambellone
di oggi non mi dai il mariachi avviarsi
novità la ricetta raffaele tutto questo
è un americano quindi a tutta una parte
di famiglia che sta qua talmente
difficile ma mi servono parli italiano
2 cost dimenticheremo mai
raffaele stava in campagna c'è la zia di
thomas e guardando un albero di fico le
fa come si chiamerà grazie dell'azienda
che bella che hanno perché anche se
la frutta non ha un maschio e bisex un
sergente fluente provato a mischiare
chiama secondo me lavorandolo
interessante invece ma sono ovviamente i
lavoratori abbiamo un frullatore che fa
tutto questo però in casa con il
minipimer è troppo densa per fare una
cosa che vogliamo aggiunge realmente
deferito aver lucani terna la zucchina
il profilo aromatico si aggiunge sempre
dopo tu puoi fare o 5 10 o 15 in base al
gusto che cioè figura o guarda quant'è
bello
l'odore allora si può aggiungere anche
l'estratto di vaniglia quelle queste
cose cugini della cannella che mi
allenavo va più di moda in america si
prende movimenti classici quali potete
farvelo come vi pare non si suppone è
proprio una paletta e non possiamo acqua
per quale motivo quando cioè acqua è un
prodotto così hai bisogno di un
conservante che è l'acqua e l'ambiente
che favorisce la crescita dei batteri e
non usando solo lì non dobbiamo usare un
osservato perchè se farà un presepe che
voleva che imparzialmente dove l'italia
the actions meraviglioso gruppo viene
voglia di mangiarlo posso dire sì sembra
un calo di infilare è totalmente
naturale totalmente naturale dura al
mese se nei momenti in frigo può durare
due mesi quindi non fai una quantità
eccessiva o vanno il colore bellissimo
scorcio è una zaza insegnerà d'oro la
consistenza cerchiamo di capire se l'ho
infilato tutto quanto bene dentro
no è perfetto è perfetto e ti dico ci
pare mai il buco e sa che già da questo
ce l'abbiamo solo far migliorare da
senti non ci possiamo toccare ma è come
se ti stessi eliminando in questo è un
gratta la pazzia
andiamo questo lo chiudiamo ragazze
ragazzi vuol dire tanto per me questo
qui è il dentifricio di raffello due
settimane di prova ne torno a casa e
proprio tutto quantità eccezionale poi
vediamo
l'efficace e poi ti voglio dire questo
prodotto non ha
una flora marina floro è quindi non va
usato per sempre va usato per due
settimane ogni sei mesi è importante
perché è come quando vai a fare bianca
mento dal dentista non si fa ogni mese
si fa due volte all'amore volta all'anno
questo si usa per due settimane due
volte all'anno fine poi di ristrettezze
mesi questo era utilissime dovere a
tutto qua andiamo a provarlo grazie alla
fiera che mette mangia gli spaghetti al
nero di ceppi ogni volta
[Musica]
mica che stiamo qualche alla fine siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video è
arrivato il momento che aspettavo io ho
cercato di seguire al meglio le
indicazioni di raffaele non sono stato
sempre perfetto ora rullo di tamburi la
domanda che tutti ci stiamo facendo
almeno io mi sto facendo funziona o no
non lo saprò finché non sarà montato
quindi dobbiamo fare un paragone tra
imminente adesso è all'inizio di tutto
questo percorso con franco rina che
cambia se ha funzionato si funziona
che bello fatelo anche voi a casa vostra
vi lasciamo qui sotto il link degli
ingredienti ovviamente che ha usato
raffaele anche altro dirvi iscrivetevi a
questo canale
mi raccomando attivate la campanella in
modo da non perdere i nostri video ci
aiuterete un sacco o lasciateci un light
ma soprattutto fatemi sapere se
effettivamente vi rendete conto se c'è
una differenza oppure no perché
ovviamente io adesso non l'ho visto
ancora perché il risultato senza ancora
vedere il montato ciao